I'm not sure the legacy of George W Bush
will be the legacy that he thought it
would be when he took office no doubt
the legacy will be how Iraq turns out no
matter what George W Bush thinks in my
view about what his legacy will be it
will be inextricably linked to the war
if the war is ultimately seen as a
successful effort against terrorism and
a successful military venture by the
United States then his legacy will be
good if it's seen ultimately as a
disastrous effort to stop Saddam Hussein
from utilizing weapons of mass
destruction and a effort to keep al
Qaeda from coming United States it may
be viewed differently if a terrorism
attack occurs the United States it may
be viewed one way if no terrorism attack
occurs here for five years ten years in
the future his effort may be looked at
differently I think the president is
very much inspired by Harry Truman's
situation Harry Truman left Washington
in 1953 when dwight eisenhower became
president a very unpopular person of his
popularity ratings were probably fifteen
to nineteen percent and nobody had a big
send-off for him he walked it to the
train station essentially and went back
to Missouri in hindsight people think
that Harry Truman was a great president
in hindsight they think he did some very
courageous things I think George Bush is
propelled to think that the same thing
might happen to him that five years 10
years 15 years down the road people will
say well it's a good thing that he
fought the war in Iraq because of things
that developed subsequently I don't
think we have that perspective today I
think today the war is not that popular
for sure and George Bush isn't viewed
today as Harry Truman is viewed today
but I think he views it possible
possibly the case that he will be viewed
that way